on sait jamais combien donner aux
enfants c'est comme les pourboires pour
nous c'est rien mais on veut surtout pas
que ça fasse trop pour eux
donc si ça vous intéresse je vous donne
les prix qui se pratique en moyenne en
france
pour vous situer par rapport aux autres
adeptes de l'humour absurde chris
esquerre s'est fait connaître du grand
public en 2012 sur canal+ d'abord
chroniqueur à l'édition spéciale puis au
grand journal
et enfin un animateur pour france inter
il a mis du temps avant de s'aventurer
sur scène il m'a fallu beaucoup d'années
avant d'avoir le courage de le faire
ça me paraissait plus facile de faire de
la radio et de la télévision et je suis
venu en dernier enfin j'ai d'abord fait
la radio puis la télévision et la scène
est venue après parce que ça me
paraissait très dur j'ai dû me faire
violence au début en fait ça me faisait
vraiment peur mais je les fais par
curiosité je me suis dit je peux pas
rester comme ça planqué en ayant peur
d'affronter la scène après un diplôme en
finance chris esquerre devient
consultant d'une entreprise de conseil
mais il démissionne trois ans plus tard
pour suivre sa véritable vocation de sa
vie en entreprise il en a écrit un
spectacle où ils caricaturent les
discours pince sans rire des réunions à
vider le lave-vaisselle c'est gratuit
attention certains enfants indélicats
essaierons de faire passer ça pour une
prestation payante
c'est faux
vous faites pas avoir une tombe de la
pelouse c'est environ 2 euros selon la
surface pour la réfection complète d'une
toiture
on peut pousser jusqu'à 5 euros ce qui
fait quand même une belle économie par
rapport à un professionnel donc vous
voyez on est en bas là on arrive à
amortir l'enfant si je puis dire c'est
pas un travail marketing quoi je ne
cherche pas des vannes qui pourrait
offrir des gens je veux montrer ce qui
moi m'a fait rieur effectivement c'est
la scène c'est un grand c'est une forme
de partage après son passage à buc
l'humoriste se lance désormais dans
l'écriture de son deuxième seul en scène
il le présentera en octobre 2016 à lille